you've become friends with Patrick
Stewart oh yeah the great Patrick
Stewart he's a knight he's at night and
it's interesting because I don't I I you
don't seem like two people that would I
see him hanging out with like another
refined old English actor so I how did
you guys become friends uh weirdly
enough through comedy I do an improv
show called the improvised Shakespeare
Company and then he is actually sat in
with us he's done improv with us in
Shakespearean format that's he must be
brilliant at that he is surprisingly
incredible for someone who's never taken
formal improv training obviously knows
the Shakespeare part down his improv is
a lot of like ah now I've caught off
your penis and I'm taking it away we're
like uh yeah let's justify that somehow
like wrestle him down yeah but he's so
funny he really does have a funny bone I
he was saying to me that it got coaxed
out of him in extras you know with Ricky
Gervais Stephen Merchant when he was
like it's true late their clothes are
off when I've seen everything if you
haven't seen it my god go watch it and
he really sort of got into comedy
through that he you guys got into a
back-and-forth on Instagram I would say
a playful feud which turned pretty
intense actually yeah I was shooting
Godzilla 2 which will be out next year
I'm sure who knows when yeah last summer
in Atlanta I was just so bored you know
on these big movies you work and then
you have weeks working to nothing and
I'm just sitting around in my olanta
hotel room being like I'm gonna try and
start a feud with Patrick Stewart I said
did some stupid Instagram video you know
like firing a shot off the old bow yeah
yep yeah and he he fired back well he
fired back and he made this he that's
you scrubbing a floor
so then you fired back at him and you
put him on a stair lift then he fired
back at you and you're making a pizza
for some reason I think you won that
exchange then you fired back at him and
you're putting him to bed in a hospital
well he was he was uh he was making out
like I was I'm his servant so I was
making it like okay well all right my
old master you're my old master then he
finally I think he won because he has
you massaging him and then with the line
lower-middle [ __ ] lower I think he won
yeah I fully concede victory to him not
only and also like he has a lot more
followers of me and when I was and I had
started this little I thought was
clearly put playful but I would go down
his comments and so many people are like
who is this loser Middleditch guy let's
get him like they were so mad like how
dare he this yeah fessor ex needs the
Verizon guy screwed you're the Verizon
yeah
you